This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. You have the desire to help a real difference? The College, LaCite, you offer the program Dependance and Scenti Mental. Acquare the competences essential
这是一个IHeart播客。保证真实。您是否有意愿去做出真正的改变？LaCite学院为您提供“依赖与心理健康”课程。获取必备技能，
for accompanying and support the people confronted to the challenges and to find out to service of the community francophone of all the
以陪伴和支持那些面临挑战的人们，并为各地的法语社区服务。
country. Don't know the health in French, it's possible with the CIT. Visit Collage LAC.C.
想用法语了解健康知识吗？在CIT可以实现。请访问Collage LAC.C。
D.M.C. a initiative of the initiative National of Formation in Health Souttened by Santee Canada. There was no anything inside
D.M.C.是加拿大卫生部支持的“国家健康培训倡议”的一项举措。那些眼睛里什么都没有。
those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Creveh and DePippo.
它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。邪恶，醒醒。我是那个亲眼目睹Creveh和DePippo谋杀案的人。
Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil.
安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后表现得毫无悔意，似乎并未受到影响。我说，我没有罪。我会把这带进坟墓。听听《魔鬼》。
Quarri in the Bone Valley feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential, and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby. If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《骨谷采石场》。快乐至关重要，但也难以捉摸，但现在有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开启您通往更快乐生活的旅程，那就是《快乐101》。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比主持的新播客。如果您渴望获得灵感来最大化您的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心且感人的直播聊天。打开您免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索“快乐101”并立即收听。
Joy 101 with Hoda Kotfi is presented by CVS. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier El Chicharito Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Here. Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. For years, the Un-House has been presented as a monolith in mainstream media.
由CVS呈现的《霍达·科特比的快乐101》。每个人都视我为足球运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何面对问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的，只是关于活着的意义的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯，在IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《学习做人》。多年来，无家可归者在主流媒体中一直被呈现为一个单一的群体。
Wheatian House is a podcast that's changing the narrative. I'm Theo Henderson, and I created this show why I was Un-Housed on the streets of Los Angeles. We've grown into a two-time Webby Award-winning podcast, the only podcast that shares Un-House stories and news from the Un-House perspective. Listen to Wey and Howls on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello everybody. I'm Jemma Spake and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello, everybody.
《无家可归者》是一个正在改变叙事的播客。我是西奥·亨德森，我在洛杉矶街头无家可归时创建了这个节目。我们已经成长为一个两度获得威比奖的播客，也是唯一一个从无家可归者视角分享无家可归者故事和新闻的播客。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《无家可归者》。大家好。我是杰玛·斯佩克，欢迎回到《二十岁的心理学》，这是一个我们探讨二十岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。
Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode. Today, we are talking about a very insidious part of our 20s. The pressure to be extraordinary. The pressure to be the best. To be the Wondikind. To be the star.
欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴您能回来收听新的一集。今天，我们要谈论二十岁时一个非常阴险的部分。成为非凡人物的压力。成为最优秀者的压力。成为神童的压力。成为明星的压力。
This idea that if we don't make it big now in our 20s, we will never have what it takes. This feeling follows us around everywhere. And I personally think it destroys a lot of our organic love for so many things. And it destroys our ability to be truly curious and truly passionate during a time in our lives when that is like our number one asset. I cannot be the only one who feels this implicit sense that we are all in this race. And we are all losing at the exact same time. We're all in the race.
这种想法认为，如果我们现在二十岁时没有取得巨大成功，我们就永远不会具备成功所需的素质。这种感觉无处不在地跟随我们。我个人认为，它摧毁了我们对许多事物原本的纯粹热爱。它摧毁了我们在生命中本该充满好奇心和激情的时期保持这种状态的能力，而这本是我们最重要的资产。我肯定不是唯一一个感受到这种隐含的“我们都在这场竞赛中，而且我们都在同时输掉比赛”的感觉的人。我们都在竞赛中。
None of us are winning. There are like 10 or 12 people in this world, 10 or 12 amazing 20 somethings who are Olympians, who are business owners, who are authors, who are experts, they're winning, but we are not. And the question always seems to be like, why can't that be me? Why didn't I make it? Why don't I have the motivation to be this extraordinary person? Does that mean that I am less than? It is so exhausting.
我们中没有人赢。世界上大约有10到12个人，10到12个了不起的二十多岁的人，他们是奥运选手、企业主、作家、专家，他们赢了，但我们没有。问题似乎总是：“为什么那个人不能是我？为什么我没有成功？为什么我没有动力成为这个非凡的人？”这是否意味着我不如别人？这太让人精疲力竭了。
And I think we really need to dissect where that comes. comes from, from a psychological standpoint, what it does to our ambition. I also want to talk about the role of viral fame, how that has changed our interpretation of what it means to be extraordinary, the gifted child phenomena, all of these things, but mainly the personal cost of this pressure to be extraordinary that just seemingly follows us around everywhere and why our current version of what is extraordinary is probably deeply, deeply flawed and deeply. deeply wrong. So without further ado, I feel like this is the pep talk I need right now. This is an important episode for me as well. Let's get into it. What doesn't mean to be extraordinary
我认为我们真的需要从心理学的角度剖析这种压力来自哪里，以及它对我们的抱负有什么影响。我还想谈谈病毒式成名的作用，它如何改变了我们对“非凡”含义的解读，天才儿童现象，所有这些事情，但主要是这种似乎无处不在的“成为非凡人物”的压力所带来的个人代价，以及为什么我们目前对“什么是非凡”的定义可能存在深刻的、严重的缺陷和错误。所以，废话不多说，我觉得这正是我现在需要的鼓励。这一集对我来说也很重要。让我们开始吧。在现代社会，成为非凡人物意味着什么？
in modern society right now? I think there are a few major themes that spring to mind. The biggest being fame, money, status items, being busy, being the best, accomplishing, as much as possible in a very short time. It is all very visible, isn't it? And it's all very dependent on external validation. It's all very hyper-competitive. The appeal of external validation and meeting those external expectations
我想到了几个主要主题。最大的是名声、金钱、地位象征、忙碌、成为最优秀的人、在极短的时间内完成尽可能多的事情。这一切都非常显眼，不是吗？而且这一切都非常依赖外部验证。这一切都具有极强的竞争性。对外部验证和满足那些外部期望的渴望，
for what success looks like is very understandable at this time in our lives, at this stage, in our 20s. In our 20s, there are so many unknowns in front of us. like there is so much that we don't understand it is only natural that we fixate on this very narrow vision of what extraordinary is that we know guarantees us approval because that makes us feel steady striving to be exceptional can provide a kind of emotional security but also a social security that we don't often we don't really get from anything else like this is the blueprint if we follow it
在我们的二十岁这个人生阶段是非常可以理解的。在二十岁时，我们面前有太多的未知。我们不理解的事情太多了，所以我们自然会专注于这种非常狭隘的“非凡”定义，因为我们知道这能保证我们获得认可，这让我们感到稳定。努力变得卓越可以提供一种情感安全感，也是一种我们通常无法从其他任何地方获得的社会安全感。这就是蓝图，如果我们遵循它，
Well, all these people who have found the success seem happy. So we must be happy as well. We will be happy if we find that validation also. The social validation in particular that comes with visible success from your friends and family praising you right up to viral internet fame is very seductive, but it also limits our version of what a successful life looks like to only something that can be seen and praised. You never see people bragging about the quality of their time off, the devotion to their hobbies. You never see people bragging about how deeply they've gotten to know themselves or how much rest do they get.
好吧，所有这些取得成功的人似乎都很幸福。所以我们也必须幸福。如果我们找到那种验证，我们也会幸福。特别是那种伴随着可见成功而来的社会验证，从朋友和家人的赞美，一直到互联网上的病毒式成名，是非常诱人的，但它也将我们对成功生活的定义限制在只能被看见和赞美的事物上。你从不会看到人们炫耀他们休息时间的质量，对爱好的投入。你从不会看到人们炫耀他们对自己了解得有多深，或者他们得到了多少休息。
There's no prize for being the best kind of friend or for surviving hard emotional things. We have one version of success. Either you are that. Either you are fame, luxury, money, or you're not successful. That is what society says. I think this has in part been, and I know has been intensified by social media in two ways. Firstly, the rise of viral fame that can take somebody from like seemingly ordinary to extraordinary in the span of hours and like change your life, your status, your bank account balance overnight. This is the first time in human history that this could be somebody's pipeline, that this could be somebody's life.
成为最好的朋友或从艰难的情感困境中走出来是没有奖项的。我们只有一种成功版本。要么你是那种人。要么你有名声、奢侈、金钱，要么你就不成功。这就是社会所说的。我认为这在一定程度上被社交媒体以两种方式加剧了。首先，病毒式成名的兴起，可以在几小时内让一个人从看似普通变得非凡，并在一夜之间改变你的生活、地位和银行账户余额。这是人类历史上第一次有人能走这条路，有人能过这种生活。
and that makes extraordinary or being extraordinary feel so much more accessible. Genuinely, like fame, even like 20 years ago, 30 years ago, fame used to be like a slow burn. It used to be exclusive and it used to be reserved for people who were really dedicated to a craft or who were perhaps became like sensational stars overnight. I actually read a study the other day that interviewed like, I don't know, I think like teen teenagers, like thousands of teenagers who are like, and actually even younger children, like 10, 11, 12, 13 year old kids on what their dream job would be. And the majority of them said like YouTuber, online gamer or influencer.
这让“非凡”或“成为非凡人物”感觉触手可及。真的，就像名声，即使是20年前、30年前，名声也往往是缓慢积累的。它曾经是排他的，是留给那些真正致力于某种技艺的人，或者是那些可能一夜之间成为轰动明星的人。我前几天读到一项研究，采访了，我不知道，我想是青少年，成千上万的青少年，甚至更小的孩子，比如10、11、12、13岁的孩子，问他们的梦想工作是什么。大多数人说的是：YouTuber、网络游戏玩家或网红。
This, like the viral fame makes it feel so much more in reach for so many more people to be this extraordinary person. And that ups the pressure. The second way I think social media has intensified the need to be extraordinary is that unlike our parents' generation who could probably only really compare themselves to the people that they know or mutual friends or, I don't know, people their age who like made it bigger and who were like in the paper, who were like public figures. You and I, like we now have the entire online world to compare ourselves to. We are flooded with opportunities to see how we measure up against our peers, literally everybody, people our own age who appear to be killing it from like all over the world. Like I don't, you would not have to search very far to find somebody your age from your part of the world who looks like you doing things that are just insanely cool and amazing. And they are one in a million, but we see a million of them a day.
这种病毒式成名让更多人觉得成为这种非凡的人触手可及。这增加了压力。我认为社交媒体加剧“成为非凡人物”需求的第二种方式是，与我们父母那一代人不同，他们可能只能真正地与他们认识的人、共同的朋友，或者我不知道，与他们同龄的那些取得了更大成就、出现在报纸上、成为公众人物的人进行比较。你和我，我们现在拥有整个在线世界来与自己进行比较。我们被淹没了，到处都是机会去看看我们与同龄人的差距，字面上是所有人，来自世界各地、看起来非常成功的同龄人。你不需要费力就能找到一个和你同龄、来自你所在地区、看起来和你一样、做着极其酷和了不起的事情的人。他们是百万分之一，但我们每天能看到一百万个这样的人。
We don't see, like, the normal lives. We don't see the tough bits unless they want us to see it. We don't see, we only see, like, the people who have broken through a very tricky algorithm to reach our screen or to reach, like, our public knowledge or, like, our public, yeah, the public arena. And this creates a cognitive fallacy that if these are the only people we see online, everybody else must, like it must be accessible. These people were just like us before they got here.
我们看不到正常的生活。除非他们想让我们看到，否则我们看不到艰难的部分。我们只看到那些突破了非常棘手的算法而出现在我们屏幕上，或者进入我们的公众认知或公共领域的人。这产生了一种认知谬误：如果这些是我们在线上看到的唯一人，那么其他人一定也……这一定是可以实现的。这些人到达这里之前和我们一样。
And everybody could have this. So why don't we? In a more professional context as well, I think LinkedIn has done that for even more traditional career paths as well. Obviously not everybody wants to be an influencer or a YouTuber. But LinkedIn does that for finance, for consulting, for law, for accounting. There was a 2016 study that assessed a sample of, 1,700 university students and measured the correlation between LinkedIn usage and depression and social anxiety. And they found that participants who used LinkedIn at least once per week were
每个人都可以拥有这一切。那么为什么我们没有呢？在更专业的背景下，我认为LinkedIn对更传统的职业道路也做了同样的事情。显然不是每个人都想成为网红或YouTuber。但LinkedIn对金融、咨询、法律、会计领域也是如此。2016年的一项研究评估了1700名大学生样本，测量了LinkedIn使用率与抑郁和社交焦虑之间的相关性。他们发现，每周至少使用一次LinkedIn的参与者，
much more likely to have these indicators of poor and mental health. And that's the problem with constantly striving to be extraordinary at this age. Extraordinary feels exceedingly normal because of how cases of extraordinary people are everywhere and rise to the surface and dominate what we see because it's exciting. It's exciting and alluring to see somebody make it. And this, of course, breeds a very deep incidious form of social comparison. I should say this. Social comparison in itself is not a bad thing. I actually think it's a useful thing. It's completely normal to look around you and to look at others for like information about how what you should be doing and how you think and how you feel and how you should behave. It provides an incredible evolutionary advantage in a highly complex and
更有可能出现这些心理健康状况不佳的指标。这就是在这个年龄段不断努力变得非凡的问题所在。因为非凡的人随处可见，并浮出水面主导了我们的视野，所以“非凡”感觉极其正常，因为这很令人兴奋。看到某人成功是令人兴奋和诱人的。当然，这滋生了一种非常深刻、阴险的社会比较形式。我应该说，社会比较本身并不是一件坏事。我实际上认为它是有用的。环顾四周，从他人那里获取关于你应该做什么、如何思考、如何感受以及如何表现的信息，这是完全正常的。在一个高度复杂和
interconnected modern social world, knowing what is the norm is often good for social standing. But there are obvious problems that come with constantly looking at other people to validate our lives and our choices, especially when what we see of them may be incorrect. or probably is the incomplete picture. I came across this article written by this woman. I cannot remember her name, but she was on the 30 under 30 list in 2018. If you don't know what the Forbes 30 under 30 list is, it's like basically a list of 30 people aged 30 and under who have done like really impressive things.
相互关联的现代社会中，了解什么是常态通常对社会地位有好处，这提供了惊人的进化优势。但不断地看着别人来验证我们的生活和选择，显然会带来问题，特别是当我们所看到的可能是不正确的，或者很可能是不完整的图景时。我偶然读到一位女士写的文章。我不记得她的名字了，但她是2018年“30位30岁以下精英”榜单上的人。如果你不知道福布斯“30位30岁以下精英”榜单是什么，它基本上是一份30岁及以下、做出了非常令人印象深刻的事情的30人名单。
And it's like a real thing to get on this list. And this woman, this author of this article, talks about how the award, it doesn't account for the whole picture of people's lives. It doesn't look at the facts of their achievements. It doesn't think about, it doesn't weigh up who was self-made versus who had family support. It doesn't weigh up their failures. She points to when Forbes, there was like a really famous article a couple of years about. about like Kylie Jenna being like the first self-made billionaire woman on one of its covers. And in this article, this woman talks about how like this list, that's an example of how they
能进入这个名单是一件大事。这位文章作者谈到了这个奖项如何不能反映人们生活的全貌。它不看成就背后的事实。它不考虑、不权衡谁是白手起家，谁有家庭支持。它不权衡他们的失败。她指出了几年前福布斯的一篇非常著名的文章，关于凯莉·詹娜作为第一位白手起家的女性亿万富翁登上封面。在这篇文章中，这位女士谈到了这个榜单是如何成为他们
fetishize achievement, but they erase the role of privilege and access. Like they only spotlight the individual, not the system, not all the stuff that went right for them, not all the luck they have. Or even not what, like they never talk about what went wrong or anything that isn't glamorous. I'm like I'm totally blanking on her name. I'm going to leave a link below. It is such a good article. It's on Vox if you want to read it. And again, this woman who wrote this article was a Forbes 30 under 30 like awardee. Like she belongs to this extremely tiny group. Just 30 people under 30 every year who are deemed to be extraordinary. And if she is calling out the lack of transparency with young people and the true stories of people who achieve these huge milestones and how it's not all that it seems, like, I think we should listen and I think we should acknowledge that the, I don't know, the idols that we have, the visions or the views or the pictures of success we have are probably not correct. I think part of the pressure to be extraordinary also comes down to hustle culture.
将成就神圣化，却抹杀了特权和资源的作用的例子。他们只聚焦于个人，而不是系统，不是所有对他们有利的事情，不是他们所有的运气。甚至他们从不谈论出了什么问题，或者任何不光鲜亮丽的事情。我完全想不起她的名字了。我会在下面留下一个链接。这是一篇非常好的文章。如果你想读的话，它在Vox上。再说一次，写这篇文章的女士是一位福布斯“30位30岁以下精英”获奖者。她属于这个极小的群体。每年只有30位30岁以下的人被认为是非凡的。如果她都在呼吁年轻人缺乏透明度，呼吁那些取得这些巨大里程碑的人的真实故事，以及事情并非看起来那样，我认为我们应该倾听，我认为我们应该承认，我们拥有的偶像、愿景或对成功的看法可能是不正确的。我认为“成为非凡人物”的压力部分也归结于“奋斗文化”。
Very obvious. Hustle culture, this idea that we should always be on, always should be burning the midnight oil, or always should be optimizing our free time is everywhere. Like they villainize free time. Time spent relaxing is times you should be spent, like that should be spent working and pushing ourselves harder. And there's this whole narrative of like pressure is privilege. I've been saying more and more videos on TikTok and Instagram that are like, I can't complain when there's work to, like when there's work to do. Like I can't complain that my plate is full when I wanted to eat. I can't complain about the pressure that I wanted. Like that's this whole mentality.
非常明显。奋斗文化，这种认为我们应该一直处于开启状态，应该一直熬夜工作，或者应该一直优化我们的空闲时间的想法，无处不在。他们将空闲时间妖魔化。花在放松上的时间本应是应该花在工作和更加努力推动自己上的时间。而且有一种“压力就是特权”的叙事。我在TikTok和Instagram上看到越来越多的视频说：“当有工作要做时，我不能抱怨。”“当我想吃东西时，我不能抱怨我的盘子满了。”“我不能抱怨我想要的压力。”这就是那种心态。
of like if you're not suffering and working hard, you're not deserving. Even the things that are purely done for enjoyment these days need to be maximized. Literally maximizing is the trend, like hobby maxing, looks maxing, life maxing, outside maxing, flow state, maxing. Like I could go on. Everything needs to be maximized. It's created this lingering sense that we have to be fantastic at all our hobbies. We always have to be gearing towards monetizing them.
如果你不痛苦、不努力工作，你就不配。甚至那些纯粹为了享受而做的事情，如今也需要最大化。字面上，“最大化”是一种趋势，比如爱好最大化、外貌最大化、生活最大化、户外最大化、心流状态最大化。我可以一直列举下去。一切都需要最大化。这产生了一种挥之不去的感官，即我们必须在所有的爱好上都表现得非常出色。我们必须总是朝着将它们货币化的方向努力。
We need to strive to be extraordinarily beautiful, happy, fun, rested, successful, friendly. We have to have everything in order to like just be normal. Or especially I think the idea is like in order to be satisfied. again, partly because of how visible our lives are now. Everything needs to be for an audience. Everything needs to be, and you need to have the most of the things, the most of everything that you can get. Everything needs to be balanced to perfection.
我们需要努力变得非凡地美丽、快乐、有趣、休息充分、成功、友好。我们必须拥有一切，才能仅仅是“正常”。或者我认为特别的想法是，为了感到满足。同样，部分原因是我们的生活现在是多么可见。一切都需要为了观众。一切都需要，你需要拥有最多的东西，你能得到的一切东西。一切都需要平衡到完美。
And I think they really, like, they start us young when it comes to this pressure. Obviously, I'm blaming social media. I think that this comes down to a lot more complex ideas than just that. I have to say, if you were a gifted to, child or an overachiever, as a teenager, this next bit of this episode is for you. Because the straight A student to burnt out 20 something pipeline is so real. I think the pressure to be extraordinary in our 20s begins with the obsession with excessively smart, talented, wonder kin, like type people when we were children,
我认为他们真的，当谈到这种压力时，他们让我们从小就开始。显然，我在责怪社交媒体。我认为这归结于比这复杂得多的想法。我必须说，如果你是一个天才儿童或是一个过度成就者，作为一个青少年，这一集的下一部分是给你的。因为“全A学生到精疲力竭的二十多岁”的管道是如此真实。我认为我们二十岁时“成为非凡人物”的压力始于我们小时候对极其聪明、有天赋、神童类人的痴迷，
like the accelerator programs, the child savant, the bragging rights like our parents received. Everybody wanted a gifted child. And it actually ends up being a little bit of a curse. Of course, like, it's only natural that our society praises and wants to celebrate intelligence and wants to celebrate, you know, being talented. But boxing a child into that identity, so young and during such a form of, of time for their self-concept does psychological damage long term because it delivers the expectation that you can never deviate from this identity as the star for the rest of your life you will have
比如加速计划、儿童天才、我们父母获得的吹嘘资本。每个人都想要一个天才儿童。但这最终变成了一个小小的诅咒。当然，我们的社会赞美并想要庆祝智慧，想要庆祝有天赋，这是很自然的。但将一个孩子框定在那种身份中，在他们自我概念形成的如此早期的阶段，长期来看会造成心理伤害，因为它传递了一种期望：你永远不能偏离这个“明星”身份，在你的余生中，你将
to continue to be the best like your trajectory is set you're a you were a gifted child you better be a gifted adult and if you deviate that's because you messed up you've squanded your potential. You didn't work hard enough. But adult life isn't the same as our lives as children or even as teenagers. There's a much bigger playing field. We have so many other options open to us that weren't there before. There's a whole new set of challenges to balance. That means that when we're exposed to people or environments or situations that are challenging or where we aren't the smartest person in the room or we aren't the most talented person in the room after being told to believe that we always would be from a young age, it can be really, really jarring.
必须继续成为最优秀的人。你的轨迹已经设定好了，你曾经是一个天才儿童，你最好成为一个天才成年人。如果你偏离了，那是因为你搞砸了，你浪费了你的潜力。你工作不够努力。但成年生活与我们作为孩子甚至作为青少年的生活不同。有一个更大的竞技场。我们有许多以前没有的其他选择。有一整套新的挑战需要平衡。这意味着当我们接触到具有挑战性的人、环境或情况，或者当我们不是房间里最聪明的人，或者在从小被告知要相信自己总是最聪明、最有天赋之后，却发现自己不是最有天赋的人时，这可能会非常、非常令人震惊。
Frustration can set in when we can't master new skills with ease. We might believe that we're not clever anymore, that we peaked in high school, we suffer from imposter syndrome, there is often an entire identity collapse that comes, that I think afflicts every person who was praised for being smart, creative, the best as a child who then as an adult, you know, is still smart, amazing and talented, but cannot operate at the same level that they could when they had, didn't have bills, didn't have complex relationships, didn't have global wars to worry about. I think we may wonder where our feeling of being special will come from now. Like, now that we're out of that system, how do we set ourselves apart? And so we set ourselves
当我们无法轻松掌握新技能时，挫败感就会产生。我们可能会认为自己不再聪明了，我们在高中时就达到了顶峰，我们患有冒名顶替综合症，通常会发生一种彻底的身份崩溃，我认为这折磨着每一个小时候因聪明、有创造力、最优秀而受到赞扬，但成年后虽然仍然聪明、了不起、有天赋，却无法在没有账单、没有复杂人际关系、没有全球战争需要担心时那样发挥水平的人。我想我们可能会想，现在我们的“特别感”将从何而来。就像，既然我们已经脱离了那个系统，我们如何让自己脱颖而出？于是我们设定了
on realistically high standards to achieve something that will make us feel worthy. And then we still don't feel satisfied when we get there. The truth is, a 2025 study found that former gifted children often struggle more than non-gifted children after graduation because their only coping mechanism is working harder and they struggle in environments where they just aren't those same clear metrics for them to achieve against and for them to feel validated by. Like, that's the truth. That's probably what a lot of you guys are going through right now. And the other thing that gets confusing and I kind of just mentioned it is that after high school, after university, like the idea of linear success is revealed very quickly to be a myth.
不切实际的高标准来取得一些能让我们感到有价值的东西。然后当我们到达那里时，我们仍然感到不满足。事实是，2025年的一项研究发现，曾经的天才儿童在毕业后往往比非天才儿童挣扎得更多，因为他们唯一的应对机制就是更努力地工作，而在那些没有明确指标供他们衡量、供他们获得验证的环境中，他们会感到挣扎。这就是事实。这可能就是你们很多人现在正在经历的事情。另一件让人困惑的事情，我刚才提到了，就是高中、大学毕业后，线性成功的想法很快就被揭示为一个神话。
When we were in high school, when we were in college, everything is kind of this step up. Like, we achieve this and then we achieve this, and then we climb this and then we get to the top. And when we graduate, we climb the career ladder. And every two years, we're rewarded with a promotion and we're rewarded with a raise until we get to the top of the ladder. And then we are predictably, naturally, our happiest because we have done it. and we have the success story, we always wanted to be. But like that progression is not true anymore, if it ever was true. Instead, we live in a very uncertain time for all of our careers, for all of our lives,
当我们上高中、上大学时，一切都是一种提升。我们实现了这个，然后实现了那个，然后我们攀登这个，然后我们到达顶峰。当我们毕业时，我们攀登职业阶梯。每两年，我们就会获得晋升，获得加薪，直到我们到达阶梯的顶端。然后我们就会可预测地、自然地感到最幸福，因为我们做到了。我们拥有了我们一直想要的成功故事。但这种进步不再是真的了，如果它曾经是真的话。相反，我们生活在一个对我们所有职业、我们所有生活都非常不确定的时代，
rapidly evolving technology, AI, financial crisis, a volatile job market, means that our age group isn't going to have that same sense of upward mobility and progress that a lot of other generations have. There was this woman called Eliza Filby. She wrote the book Inheritocracy and she's the one who estimated that Gen Z will have five careers and work for 15 different employers in their lifetime, whereas in the past that typically would sit around the one to two mark. When we change jobs, when we shift, industries as is necessary for us at the moment, it can make us feel like we are falling down the ladder and that we're not exceptional because taking a break, taking a detour, any kind of deviation is
快速发展的技术、人工智能、金融危机、动荡的就业市场，意味着我们这个年龄段的人不会拥有其他许多代人所拥有的那种向上流动和进步的感觉。有一位叫伊丽莎·菲尔比的女士。她写了《继承制》一书，她估计Z世代一生中将拥有五种职业，为15个不同的雇主工作，而在过去，这个数字通常在1到2左右。当我们换工作，当我们转换行业（正如我们目前所必需的那样）时，这会让我们觉得我们在从阶梯上掉下来，我们不再卓越，因为休息、绕道、任何形式的偏离都
basically like we're out of the running because, you know, compared to somebody else who didn't deviate, like we are now behind. And that is a really stressful situation to be in. Again, the pressure that puts on us, it's deeply, it's deeply anxiety inducing. It's also incredibly unproductive and actually counterintuitive. As much as I do agree pressure may be a privilege for some when a certain version of success is the be all and end all of life and you are not achieving or anywhere close to achieving that success, it actually ends up making our goals feel less achievable and reduces our motivation. This is what I want to talk about next. You know, we know where the pressure to be
基本上就像我们退出了竞争，因为与没有偏离的其他人相比，我们现在落后了。这是一种压力很大的情况。同样，这给我们带来的压力，是非常令人焦虑的。它也极其低效，实际上适得其反。尽管我确实同意压力对某些人来说可能是一种特权，但当某种版本的成功是生活的全部和终点，而你没有取得或离那种成功还很远时，它实际上最终会使我们的目标感觉更难实现，并降低我们的动力。这就是我接下来想谈的。我们知道“成为非凡人物”的压力
extraordinary comes from. We know that we're kind of set up to fail in many ways. Now, what does it actually do to our motivational systems and our mental health? When our only version of what would make us happy or what would constitute a good life is this outdated model of like the brilliant young individual. We're going to talk about that and so much more. more after this short break. Pride is like love. You feel it in your heart. IR. Radio.
来自哪里。我们知道我们在很多方面注定要失败。现在，它实际上对我们的动机系统和心理健康有什么影响？当我们唯一能让我们快乐或构成美好生活的版本是这种过时的“杰出的年轻个人”模式时。我们将在短暂的休息后讨论这一点以及更多内容。自豪感就像爱。你能在心中感受到它。IHeart Radio。
Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts, including IHart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must have party bangers, plus personalized and curated playlists like back in the day pride. Come together, celebrate love. Take pride with you anytime, anywhere. Just ask your smart speaker to play IHart Pride Canada. Stream us on your phone. Well, and listen now at iHeartRadio.ca.
加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用程序，包括IHeart Pride Canada，您最喜爱的热门歌曲和必备派对金曲，以及个性化和精选的播放列表，如“回到过去”自豪感。聚在一起，庆祝爱。随时随地带上自豪感。只需让您的智能音箱播放IHeart Pride Canada。在您的手机上流媒体播放。好吧，现在就在iHeartRadio.ca收听。
In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir.
在那一刻，感觉它好像永远在持续。我以为我活不下去了。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里什么都没有。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一个谋杀案吗？是的，长官。
Fear to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for a child. Just as bad as it gets. I would think so. wake up. I'm the woman that saw the murder take place by Creveith and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief.
害怕说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件？是的，长官。强奸并谋杀了一个孩子。这是最糟糕的情况。我想是的。醒醒。我是那个亲眼目睹Creveith和DePippo谋杀案的女人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后表现得毫无悔意，似乎并未受到影响。我说我没有罪。我会把这带进坟墓。
Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. And to hear the Devil's Quarry ad free with exclusive content, subscribe to Love for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression. I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《魔鬼的采石场》。要收听无广告且包含独家内容的《魔鬼的采石场》，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅Love for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比，《霍达·科特比的快乐101》播客的主持人。我们将一起与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话。比如当女演员奥利维亚·穆恩分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时。“我经历过乳腺癌，然后帮助我的母亲度过了乳腺癌，那更困难。有很多人了解产后抑郁症。我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。”
Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Everyone is a ton of exciting because their new star is J. Titorito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《霍达·科特比的快乐101》。每个人都非常兴奋，因为他们的新星是J. Titorito Hernandez。每个人都视我为足球
player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from?
运动员，但首先，我是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何面对问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。我仍然有很多问题。我们从哪里来？
What happens after death? How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi? Do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Varsa? From everyday and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary.
死后会发生什么？你如何处理取消文化？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇家马德里还是巴萨？从日常和平凡到深刻和非凡。
This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends, where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shared. All in this life has an order perfect and all is just. Wait, me, I'm going to pressuram and me going to be able to be able to be.
这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深入交谈，脆弱的一面会显露出来。阴谋论会被摆上桌面，目标和经验会被分享。这一切在生命中都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等等，我，我要……我将能够……
We are here to connect. The Chicharito. I'm Javier El Chicharito Hernandez and together with Iha Radio. We're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Wow. Listen to Learning to Be Human
我们在这里是为了连接。小豌豆。我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯，与IHeart Radio一起。我们将让平凡变得非凡。保持亲近。这是一个……哇。收听《学习做人》
or IHad Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. June is Black Music Month, and on the Drink Chams podcast, we're speaking with the hottest names in the culture, like Sway Lee. Do you realize how legendary you are? I appreciate that.
或IHeart Radio、Apple Podcasts，或您获取播客的任何地方。六月是黑人音乐月，在《Drink Champs》播客上，我们正在与文化界最热门的名字交谈，比如Sway Lee。“你意识到你有多传奇吗？”“我很感激。”
I'd be seeing it, but I'm like, man, I still got, like, so much more to do. Like, Prince, he dropped like 30 albums. We dropped like five right now. Like, that's the rate we got to be going. Yeah, that's a good attitude. You also hear stories from industry legends and hip-hop pioneers like Fab Five Freddy.
“我看到了，但我心想，伙计，我还有很多事情要做。比如Prince，他发行了大约30张专辑。我们现在只发行了大约5张。这就是我们必须前进的速度。”“是的，那是一个很好的态度。”您还将听到行业传奇和嘻哈先驱的故事，比如Fab Five Freddy。
I directed when the Nas' early videos. Which one? One love. Wow. I literally filmed in his apartment in Queensbridge. His moms were still up in that apartment. Nas was just beginning to take off. His pops used to live near me in Harlem.
“我执导了Nas早期的视频之一。”“哪一个？”“One Love。”“哇。我真的在他在皇后桥的公寓里拍摄的。他妈妈当时还在那间公寓里。Nas才刚刚开始起飞。他爸爸以前住在哈莱姆区我附近。”
His dad introduced him to a whole lot of, you know, conscious stuff, and he made a young prodigy. No matter the era, Drinkchamps brings you the biggest names and the most unfiltered conversations. Listen to Drink Chams from the Black Effect Podcast Network on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. So the pressure to be extraordinary does a few things. The most important being, it just creates a chronic sense of inadequacy. It also kills our motivation.
“他爸爸向他介绍了许多，你知道，有意识的东西，他造就了一个年轻的神童。”无论什么时代，《Drink Champs》都会为您带来最大的名字和最未经过滤的对话。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听来自Black Effect Podcast Network的《Drink Champs》。所以，“成为非凡人物”的压力会产生一些影响。最重要的是，它只会产生一种长期的不足感。它也会扼杀我们的动力。
It stops us from experimenting. It stops us from like sometimes doing anything at all. Let's break those down one by one. The problem with being extraordinary. is that it never lasts. Even if you do achieve everything you want, it's a mirage. You know, once you have met the expectations that you set for yourself or somebody else set for you, like the bar is always going to be raised because that is like the pure definition of extraordinary.
它阻止我们进行实验。它有时阻止我们做任何事情。让我们逐一分解。成为非凡人物的问题在于，它永远不会持久。即使你确实实现了你想要的一切，那也是海市蜃楼。你知道，一旦你达到了你为自己设定的期望，或者别人为你设定的期望，门槛总是会被提高，因为这正是“非凡”的纯粹定义。
Like it pushes boundaries. Being extraordinary is about being constantly challenged. And it runs off this hyper-competitive narrative in society. I'm sure many of us have had this experience whereby we achieve one thing. We are so happy about it for about a minute and then we are already looking towards the next thing. And the next. This feeling has a name in psychology. It's called achievement adaptation.
它突破界限。成为非凡人物就是不断受到挑战。它在社会中运行着这种极具竞争力的叙事。我相信我们许多人都经历过这种情况：我们实现了一件事。我们为此感到高兴大约一分钟，然后我们已经在展望下一件事了。以及再下一件。这种感觉在心理学中有一个名字。它被称为“成就适应”。
It's very similar to hedonic adaptation. Basically, it is the tendency to overestimate how great big achievements are going to make you feel long-term. and to essentially become desensitized to your own efforts and accomplishments such that all good feelings lose their impact over time. So basically it's like an addiction. Like you need more and more to feel happy. Every bar that you rise to meet will be raised and you will feel like you are not doing enough to get there. Some of the most like conventionally successful people you know struggle with this, this inability to look around and be like, hey, like, I'm where I always wanted to be. I'm really proud of that. I'm so proud of how far I've come. Taylor Swift is a great
它与享乐适应非常相似。基本上，它是高估大成就长期带给你的感觉的倾向，并且本质上对你自己的努力和成就变得麻木，以至于所有美好的感觉随着时间的推移都会失去影响。所以基本上它就像一种瘾。你需要越来越多才能感到快乐。你提高去满足的每一个门槛都会被提高，你会觉得你做得不够。你认识的一些最传统意义上的成功人士都在与此斗争，这种无法环顾四周并说：“嘿，我到了我一直想到的地方。我真的为此感到骄傲。我为我走了这么远感到非常自豪。”泰勒·斯威夫特是一个很好的
example, literally the most famous person in the world. I don't know if you've watched her documentary, I'm sure what many of you have, but the one from a few years ago, I think it was called like Miss Americana. There is this scene in that documentary that I think about all of the time, like constantly, it's the scene where she's like waiting to hear about Grammy nominations and she's like just written her album lover this woman has already won at that point I think a dozen Grammys and her publicist is like no you didn't you didn't win any you didn't even get nominated actually and you can see she's just like crushed she's crushed and I distinctly remember her being like well I just have to be better I have to make a better album I have to push myself more and it doesn't
例子，字面上是世界上最著名的人。我不知道你是否看过她的纪录片，我相信你们很多人都看过，但几年前的那一部，我想它叫《美国小姐》。纪录片里有一个场景，我一直都在想，不断地想，那是她等待格莱美提名消息的场景，她刚刚写完了她的专辑《Lover》。那个时候这个女人已经赢得了十几项格莱美奖，她的公关人员说：“不，你没有，你没有赢任何奖项，实际上你甚至没有获得提名。”你可以看到她就像崩溃了一样，她崩溃了。我清楚地记得她说：“好吧，我必须变得更好。我必须制作一张更好的专辑。我必须更加推动自己。”而且看起来
look like at that time that was an enjoyable thing for her. Like obviously now, and she did, she did obviously meet that new level, but being exceptional can become a bit of a curse because your worth is dependent on your ability to outperform yourself. I think when we begin to recognize this loop, that nothing is ever enough, we will never be as good as a version of us that doesn't exist or a version of other people that doesn't exist. I think that actually kills our motivation in a way because we're kind of like, why bother? Why bother trying so hard? If every time I do achieve something that goal post shift, if I'm never going to be that person, I think this logic comes into play, which is like, you know, it's better not to try it all. You know, I'd rather feel
在那个时候，那对她来说并不是一件令人愉快的事情。显然现在，她确实达到了那个新的水平，但变得卓越可能会成为一种诅咒，因为你的价值取决于你超越自己的能力。我认为当我们开始认识到这个循环时，即没有什么永远足够，我们永远不会像一个不存在的我们版本或一个不存在的他人版本那样好。我认为这实际上以一种方式扼杀了我们的动力，因为我们有点像：“为什么要费心呢？为什么要费心尝试那么努力呢？如果我每次确实实现了一些事情，那个目标就会转移，如果我永远不会成为那个人。”我认为这种逻辑发挥了作用，即：“最好根本不要尝试。你知道，我宁愿感到
unexceptional because I didn't try, then unexceptional because I did. And like, that has revealed my inadequacy. This is called learned helplessness or a version of learned helplessness called self-handicapping. So this term was coined in like the 60s, self-handicapping learned helplessness, coined in the 60s by these two researchers who basically realized, sometimes people get so adjusted and so used to being dissatisfied every time they do try that they just stop trying. Like they just realize that they're never going to be this extraordinary person, so they don't even try to be ordinary in a way.
平庸，因为我没有尝试，也不愿感到平庸，因为我尝试了，而那揭示了我的不足。”这被称为“习得性无助”，或者一种被称为“自我妨碍”的习得性无助版本。所以这个术语是在60年代左右被创造出来的，自我妨碍习得性无助，由这两位研究人员在60年代创造，他们基本上意识到，有时人们变得如此适应，如此习惯于每次尝试时都感到不满，以至于他们干脆停止了尝试。他们只是意识到他们永远不会成为这个非凡的人，所以他们甚至不去尝试以某种方式变得平凡。
When they were testing this theory on humans, Selgerman, who was one of the researchers, he would subject participants to really loud, unpleasant noises using a, lever that would not stop the sound. So basically there was a lever, they were told, I can't remember exactly, but essentially they were told that the lever would stop the sound and they were sitting in this room and the sound was really annoying, really frustrating. In the first round, that people were pulling, pulling, pulling the lever, it wasn't working. In the second round, the leather was working. But by this stage they just kind of learnt to adjust to the circumstances and they'd stop believing that they could do anything to change it. So none of them pulled the leather or like a very few of them did.
当他们在人类身上测试这一理论时，研究人员之一塞利格曼（Selgerman）会让参与者接触非常大声、令人不快的噪音，并使用一个无法停止声音的杠杆。基本上，有一个杠杆，他们被告知——我记不太清具体细节了，但本质上他们被告知杠杆可以停止声音。他们坐在房间里，声音非常烦人，非常令人沮丧。在第一轮中，人们一直在拉杠杆，但没用。在第二轮中，杠杆起作用了。但到了这个阶段，他们已经学会了适应环境，不再相信自己能做任何改变。所以他们中没有人拉杠杆，或者只有极少数人拉了。
Even though like if they had tried again, it would have worked and the sound would have gone away. They just learnt and really leaned in, learned in to this sense of helplessness that like nothing is going to change for me. The biggest result of this is a chronic state. state of apathy. When we experience prolonged exposure to not meaning our expectations, to uncomfortable situations, that we feel like we can't avoid, we can't alleviate, we're never going to be what we want to be, we effectively learn to accept the situation we are in as a given. We become stuck. We become convinced that because we can't be the most exceptional, we are doomed to mean nothing at all. It is a very black and white form of things.
即使他们再试一次，杠杆本可以起作用，声音也会消失。他们只是学会了并真正沉浸在这种无助感中，觉得“对我来说什么都不会改变”。这带来的最大后果是一种慢性的冷漠状态。当我们长期处于无法满足期望、无法避免、无法缓解的不适境地时，当我们觉得永远无法成为自己想成为的人时，我们实际上学会了接受现状，将其视为理所当然。我们被困住了。我们变得确信，因为我们无法成为最杰出的人，所以我们注定毫无意义。这是一种非常非黑即白的思维方式。
thinking. It can also mean that when we do get opportunities or we are put in luck's path, all the expectation about what that could mean for us makes us choke. This is classic performance anxiety that I think is directly derived from the pressure to be extraordinary, whereby pressure gets to a point where it's no longer motivating. It is debilitating. And it means that even when you have all the opportunities you could ask for, you cannot act on them because you are so nervous about screwing the moment. This has traditionally been observed, obviously, in athletes who are like at the final moment, they are doing something that they have done since they were children. They choke. For example, there is evidence of this happening time and time again.
它也意味着，当我们确实获得机会或处于好运之中时，所有关于这可能意味着什么的期望都会让我们感到窒息。这是典型的表现焦虑，我认为它直接源于成为非凡之人的压力，压力大到不再具有激励作用，而是具有破坏性。这意味着即使你拥有了所能要求的一切机会，你也无法采取行动，因为你太担心搞砸这一刻了。这种情况传统上显然在运动员身上观察到，比如在最后时刻，他们正在做从小就做的事情，却发挥失常。例如，有证据表明这种情况一再发生。
Research has shown that in the last 30 seconds of tight basketball games, NBA players, sorry, are I think 5.8% less likely to score from a free-fro line than at any other time in the game or during their history. They're also more likely to perform worse in front of a big home crowd. We're at risk of doing the same. Yes, we may not be playing basketball, but in job interviews, exams, during big meetings, for big opportunities, when we start gaining momentum with something we're really passionate about, We get so anxious about not doing it correctly or about the possibility that something's going to go wrong that we just, we do nothing and we feel incapable.
研究表明，在篮球比赛最后30秒的胶着时刻，NBA球员（抱歉）在罚球线上的得分率比比赛中任何其他时间或他们职业生涯中的任何时候都要低5.8%。他们在主场观众面前表现更差的可能性也更大。我们也有同样的风险。是的，我们可能不是在打篮球，但在求职面试、考试、大型会议、面对重大机会时，当我们开始对某件真正热爱的事情产生动力时，我们对做得不正确或可能出错的可能性感到如此焦虑，以至于我们什么都不做，感到无能为力。
The best way we can actually counteract this is to bring back the fun to it. Basically, when you say to yourself, like, this is meant to be fun. This isn't meant to be that serious. I'm just here to enjoy myself. I'm here to learn. I'm here to play. this is actually one of the best things you can do for this kind of pressure and this performance anxiety because you actually trigger your nervous system to calm down and to stop viewing your current situation as a threat.
我们实际上可以抵消这种压力的最好方法是找回乐趣。基本上，当你对自己说：“这本来就是为了好玩，没必要那么严肃。我只是来享受自己的，我是来学习的，我是来玩的。”这实际上是应对这种压力和表现焦虑的最好方法之一，因为你实际上触发了你的神经系统，使其平静下来，不再将当前的情况视为威胁。
Genuinely, they have done studies on this, people who counteract pressure by asking themselves, how can I enjoy this more, how can I play around with this more, how can I make a game out of this, do better. They do better. A playful mindset. is like magic because it lets you loosen your grip a little bit. And that's really what's killing a lot of this ambition and dreams is that we're so stressed. We're clinging onto it so tightly that we're like choking it. We need to be able to let things naturally move and flow. With that in mind, I think it is time that we talk about some other important mindset shifts that can lessen the pressure to be extraordinary and let you start flourishing with.
真的，他们对此做过研究，那些通过问自己“我怎样才能更享受这个过程”、“我怎样才能更多地玩转这个过程”、“我怎样才能把它变成一个游戏”来抵消压力的人，表现得更好。他们表现得更好。一种游戏心态就像魔法一样，因为它让你稍微放松一下。而这正是扼杀许多雄心和梦想的原因——我们压力太大了，我们紧紧抓住它，以至于我们像是在扼杀它。我们需要能够让事情自然地移动和流动。考虑到这一点，我认为是时候谈谈其他一些重要的心态转变了，这些转变可以减轻成为非凡之人的压力，让你开始蓬勃发展。
that and the need to be the greatest. And that the first one is the mindset of like, how can I have fun here? Another is this mantra of being like, even the ordinary can be extraordinary if I do it with care. If I do it with authenticity, if I do it with focus. Being on Forbes 30 under 30, being a CEO, being famous, getting headlines, all great. but you can be the best at anything you like that is completely small and minute. You can be the best cook in your friendship group. You can be the best at hosting your games nights. You can be the best at making Canva graphics in your workplace.
以及成为最伟大之人的需求。第一个心态是“我怎样才能在这里获得乐趣？”另一个是这样的口号：“如果我用心去做，即使是平凡的事情也可以变得非凡。”如果我带着真实感、专注力去做。登上福布斯30位30岁以下精英榜、成为CEO、出名、上头条，这些都很棒，但你可以在任何你喜欢的完全微小的事情上做到最好。你可以成为朋友圈里最好的厨师。你可以成为举办游戏之夜最棒的人。你可以成为工作场所里制作Canva图形最棒的人。
You can be the best at finding, I don't know, like remarkable Facebook marketplace deals. I have a friend like that. I genuinely think she could win a world championship. You also don't have to be the best at anything to be extraordinary. This is again, like where we need to remake our definition of extraordinary altogether. Like we need to revise that. Being extraordinary to this current world looks one certain way. And I don't know about you, but it gets rather boring.
你可以成为寻找——我不知道——比如了不起的Facebook Marketplace交易最棒的人。我有一个这样的朋友。我真心认为她可以赢得世界冠军。你也不必在任何事情上都做到最好才能变得非凡。这又是我们需要彻底重塑“非凡”定义的地方。我们需要修正它。在这个当今世界，非凡看起来是某种特定的样子。我不知道你怎么想，但这变得相当无聊。
Like it's kind of boring. Being extraordinary to you, though, might be very interesting. It might look like collecting a vast number of experiences, meeting lots of people, taking time off when you know you need it, the ability to travel whenever you want to, hopping off the so-called career ladder, doing something that you're passionate about, taking care of yourself, it may be having a lot of interesting side quests, it may be being the person who can always connect others, gaining experiences in every single way possible, not just the career way. Like there are so many other versions of extraordinary
这有点无聊。然而，对你来说，非凡可能非常有趣。它可能看起来像是收集大量的经验、结识很多人、在知道自己需要时休假、随时随地旅行的能力、跳下所谓的职业阶梯、做自己热爱的事情、照顾好自己，它可能是拥有许多有趣的支线任务，它可能是成为那个总是能连接他人的人，以各种可能的方式获得经验，而不仅仅是职业方式。有很多其他版本的非凡。
that I think are more extraordinary than what our current definition is. Like the current definition of like what makes extraordinary, again, it's kind of plain. Like making a lot of money, being very successful in a traditional way. I think at this point it's kind of like, well, I don't know, not that everybody can do it, but so many people are there and they don't seem particularly happy. Some of them don't seem like particularly fulfilled or nice people. And they don't seem like they have very fulfilling lives. The version of extraordinary that we're kind of willing to explore just like
我认为这些比我们目前的定义更非凡。目前的定义——什么造就了非凡——再次强调，它有点平庸。比如赚很多钱，以传统方式取得巨大成功。我认为在这一点上，这有点像……我不知道，并不是每个人都能做到，但很多人都达到了，他们看起来并不特别快乐。他们中的一些人看起来并不特别满足或友善。他们看起来也没有非常充实的生活。我们愿意探索的那个版本的非凡，客观上看起来更有趣，并且可能会让你体验到更多相当滋养的东西。我也认为我们的职业，专门谈论职业，你知道，是一段旅程，而不是一场比赛。如果在这个过程中你一直讨厌你所做的事情，那么它们尤其不值得成为一场比赛。再说一次，人们不会告诉你的是，那些刻板印象中的杰出人士，尤其是在早期，这本身可能就是一种“金手铐”。不仅仅是那种“天才儿童被定型”的方式，而是一种非常复杂的方式。
objectively looks more interesting and probably will lead you to experience a lot more that is like quite nourishing. I also think like our careers, speaking specifically of careers, you know, are not, they're a journey, not a race. And they're especially not worth being a race if you hate. what you're doing the entire time. And again, what people won't tell you is that people who are stereotypically exceptional, especially early on, like that in itself can be its own version of golden handcuffs. And not just in like the gifted child being pigeonholed way, but in a really complex way.
（接上文）
People who find success early on, it's not all that it's cracked up to be. They often speak about this lack of flexibility they now have. They speak about the curve. They speak about the curve. of a reputation, even a good reputation. They will always be the youngest lawyer. They will always be the teenage CEO. They will always be the athlete, the star from that one show that they made when they were 25, the person who did that one thing once when they were young. And because they were young, it was significant. That means that people question them more when they go to try new things. They see them more, or they see them only as what they used to be. And that makes, it makes it hard for them to kind of challenge assumptions, it also gives them less room to experiment.
那些早早获得成功的人，情况并不像人们吹嘘的那样。他们经常谈论他们现在缺乏灵活性。他们谈论声誉的曲线，即使是好名声。他们将永远是“最年轻的律师”。他们将永远是“十几岁的CEO”。他们将永远是那个运动员，那个在25岁时制作的那部剧里的明星，那个年轻时做过那件事的人。因为他们当时很年轻，所以这很有意义。这意味着当他们去尝试新事物时，人们会更多地质疑他们。人们更多地看到他们，或者只把他们看作他们过去的样子。这使得他们很难挑战假设，也给了他们更少的实验空间。
Experimentation in itself is extraordinary. And I think actually gives you more choice down the line because you've explored the what ifs. You've had more diverse experiences and more opportunities for learning than someone who found success in the first thing they ever did. probably, like, they probably don't have that. Not to bag on them, obviously. Like, they're very impressive people. I personally know people who are like Forbes 30 under 30. I think they're fantastic and they're very nice. But you actually do have a freedom they don't have. You have reputational freedom to be whatever you want to be. When you want to be it, not just when you're 20, and not just at something that's going to follow you around for the rest of your life. Again,
实验本身就是非凡的。而且我认为这实际上给了你更多的选择，因为你探索了“如果……会怎样”。你拥有比那些在第一件事上就获得成功的人更多样化的经历和更多的学习机会。他们可能没有这些。当然，不是要贬低他们。他们是非常令人印象深刻的人。我个人认识一些福布斯30位30岁以下精英榜的人。我认为他们很棒，人也很好。但你确实拥有他们没有的自由。你拥有声誉自由，可以成为你想成为的任何人。当你想要成为它的时候，而不是仅仅在你20岁的时候，也不是仅仅在某件会跟随你余生的事情上。再说一次，
being extraordinary, maybe aspirational. It is no guarantee. of happiness. And there's a lot of people, I mean a lot of people who are probably on your vision boards or who come to my mind and would come to your mind when we are asked to describe an exceptional or extraordinary person who are deeply, deeply miserable and who cannot have fun, cannot fail, cannot explore the way that you can as a novice. I also think there's a lot more that matters for our happiness and health than being the best. Let's talk about it some more after this short break. Pride is like love.
成为非凡，可能是一种抱负。但这并不能保证幸福。有很多人，我是说很多人，可能在你的愿景板上，或者当我们被要求描述一个杰出或非凡的人时，会出现在我的脑海中，也会出现在你的脑海中，他们内心深处非常痛苦，无法享受乐趣，无法失败，无法像新手那样去探索。我也认为，对于我们的幸福和健康来说，还有很多比成为最优秀的人更重要的事情。休息片刻后，我们再深入探讨。自豪感就像爱。
You feel it in your heart. IR. Radio. Canada's number one streaming app for radio and podcasts, including IHart Pride Canada, your favorite hits and must have party bangers, plus personalized and curated playlists like back in the day pride. Come together, celebrate love. Take pride with you. Anytime, anywhere.
你能在心中感受到它。iHeartRadio，加拿大排名第一的广播和播客流媒体应用程序，包括iHeart Pride Canada，你最喜欢的金曲和必备派对热歌，以及个性化和精心策划的播放列表，如“Back in the Day Pride”。聚在一起，庆祝爱。随时随地，带着自豪感。
Just ask your smart speaker to play iHeart Pride Canada. Stream us on your phone. Listen now at iHeartRadio.ca. In the moment, it felt like it was going on forever. I didn't think I was going to live. I was terrified. There was no anything inside those eyes. They turned black.
只需让你的智能音箱播放iHeart Pride Canada。在手机上收听我们。现在就在iHeartRadio.ca收听。那一刻，感觉好像永远持续下去。我以为我活不成了。我吓坏了。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变成了黑色。
It scared the hell out of me. That was your first murder case? Yes, sir. Fair to say this was the biggest case of your career? Yes, sir. Rape a murder for children, 12-year-old. She's as bad as it gets. I would think so.
这把我吓坏了。那是你的第一起谋杀案吗？是的，长官。可以说这是你职业生涯中最大的案件吗？是的，长官。强奸并谋杀儿童，12岁。这是最糟糕的情况。我想是的。
People wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Creveit and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
人们醒醒吧。我是那个看到克里瓦克（Creveit）和德皮波（DePippo）实施谋杀的人。安东尼·德皮波（Anthony DePippo）在被判处最高刑罚后，没有表现出任何悔意，显得泰然自若。我说我没罪。我会带着它进坟墓。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《魔鬼的采石场》（The Devil's Quarry）。
And to hear the devil's quarry ad-free with exclusive content. Subscribe to Lava for Good Plus on Apple Podcasts. Hey, I'm Hoda Kotby, host of the podcast, Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby. Together, we're going to have meaningful conversations with the world's most fascinating people. Like when actress Olivia Munn shared how she overcame fierce health challenges. I've gone through breast cancer and then helped my mother through breast cancer, and that was more difficult. There's a lot of people who understand postpartner depression.
想要收听无广告版《魔鬼的采石场》并获取独家内容，请在Apple Podcasts上订阅Lava for Good Plus。嘿，我是霍达·科特比（Hoda Kotby），播客《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》的主持人。我们将与世界上最迷人的人进行有意义的对话。比如女演员奥利维亚·穆恩（Olivia Munn）分享她如何克服严峻的健康挑战时说：“我经历过乳腺癌，然后帮助我的母亲度过乳腺癌，那更困难。有很多人了解产后抑郁症。”
I was not prepared for postpartum anxiety. Listen to Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Because their new star is Javier Tchirito Hernandez. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions ever since I was born. And I still have so many questions. Where do we come from? What happens after death?
我没有为产后焦虑做好准备。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》。因为他们的新星是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯（Javier Chicharito Hernandez）。每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何处理问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。我仍然有很多问题。我们从哪里来？死后会发生什么？
How do you deal with cancellation? Cristiano or Messi, do aliens exist? What is love? Real Madrid or Barza. From every day and ordinary to the deep and extraordinary. This isn't a normal podcast. Everything here is spontaneous, real and genuine. This podcast is like a deep talk with your closest friends,
你如何处理被取消？C罗还是梅西？外星人存在吗？什么是爱？皇马还是巴萨？从日常和平凡到深刻与非凡。这不是一个普通的播客。这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的。这个播客就像与你最亲密的朋友进行深入交谈，
where vulnerability comes out. Conspiracy theories end up on the table, and goals and lessons are shown. All in this life has an order perfect and all is just. Wait me, I'm going to be able to be. We are here to connect. The Chicharito. And Javier, Chicharito-Randes.
脆弱的一面展现出来。阴谋论被摆上台面，目标和教训被展示出来。生命中的一切都有完美的秩序，一切都是公正的。等待我，我将能够成为。我们在这里是为了连接。我是小豌豆（Chicharito）。哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯。
Together with IHard Radio, we're going to make the ordinary, extraordinary. Stay close. It is a carac. Listen to learning to be human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Keith Gianmanca seemed like a mild-mannered suburban dad, but secretly, he became someone else, a master of disguise who went on a crime spree. At the time, did it seem like a crazy idea? It seemed very crazy.
与iHeartRadio一起，我们将让平凡变得非凡。保持关注。这是一个卡拉克（carac）。在iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《学习做人》（Learning to Be Human）。基思·吉安曼卡（Keith Gianmanca）看起来像个温和的郊区父亲，但私下里，他变成了另一个人，一个走上犯罪道路的伪装大师。当时，这听起来是个疯狂的想法吗？这听起来非常疯狂。
but I felt so desperate that I felt it was the quickest, easiest way out. Did you allow yourself to think about how it could go wrong and what that might look like? No, I didn't want to manifest that. I was trying to manifest success. Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. This is going to change my life and my family dynamic forever because everything that had existed prior in my reality is now untrue. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
但我感到如此绝望，以至于我觉得这是最快、最简单的出路。你有没有让自己去想它可能会如何出错，那会是什么样子？不，我不想表现出那种想法。我试图表现出成功。每个家庭都有秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那不是一个无辜者的样子。这将永远改变我的生活和家庭动态，因为我现实中之前存在的一切现在都不真实了。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《深度潜伏：顾家男人》（Deep Cover: The Family Man）。
There's a lot more that matters for our happiness and health than being the best. And the biggest one that comes to my mind is our relationships. They never get the spotlight that professional success does. That same psychotherapist who talked about learned helplessness, Martin Silkman. He also invented the field of positive psychology, if you want another fun fact. He has conducted extensive research that shows that the strength of our relationships, whether that is with friends, family, a partner, that is the single most reliable measure of well-being, more so than fame for sure, more so than money for sure, more so than achievement,
对于我们的幸福和健康来说，还有很多比成为最优秀的人更重要的事情。我脑海中浮现出的最重要的一点是我们的关系。它们从未像职业成功那样受到关注。那位谈论习得性无助的心理治疗师马丁·塞利格曼（Martin Seligman），如果你想要另一个有趣的事实，他还创立了积极心理学领域。他进行了广泛的研究，表明我们关系的强度，无论是与朋友、家人还是伴侣的关系，是衡量幸福感最可靠的单一指标，肯定比名声更可靠，肯定比金钱更可靠，比成就更可靠，
more so than accomplishment, all these things that we think are hallmarks and will determine a good life, none of it, all of it pales in comparison to close relationships. Close relationships, more than money, more than fame, are what keep people fulfilled and happy throughout their lives. Again, sometimes we need this grounding reminder. If you are solely focused on being impressive or being seen in a certain way, that it means you don't spend time with your friends. You don't focus on being somebody who can love and be loved. Like, those things are going to carry you so much further. And the people who sacrifice that do miss out in a way that you may not be.
比功绩更可靠，所有这些我们认为是标志并决定美好生活的因素，都无法与亲密关系相提并论。亲密关系，比金钱、比名声更能让人一生充实和快乐。再说一次，有时我们需要这种扎实的提醒。如果你只专注于给人留下深刻印象或以某种方式被看待，这意味着你没有花时间与朋友在一起。你不专注于成为一个能够爱与被爱的人。那些事情会带你走得更远。而那些牺牲了这一点的人，确实会以一种你可能不会的方式错失良机。
The final reminder, the final mindset shift I have for you today is to remember, fulfillment and your dreams and executing your purpose has no deadline. there is no expiration date. This is the curse I think a lot of us struggle with in our 20s. If I am not all that I want to be by a certain age, well, it's never going to happen. I simply don't believe that's true. And I don't see any evidence for that being true either. I can give you like a very cliche list.
最后的提醒，我今天给你的最后一个心态转变是记住：实现梦想和执行你的目标没有截止日期。没有保质期。我认为这是我们许多人在20多岁时挣扎的诅咒。如果我在某个年龄之前没有达到我想要的一切，好吧，那永远不会发生了。我根本不相信这是真的。而且我也没有看到任何证据证明这是真的。我可以给你列一个非常陈词滥调的清单。
You guys have probably seen of all those people, Oprah, Harrison Ford, Vera Wang, like Morgan Freeman, who have become successes at 40, But I just think in everyday life, there are so many stories if you start looking for them of people who have found success at ages that are never highlighted or that we would never expect success to come to us at. I'm going to give you an example. And it's a really weird one. But I was in Amsterdam the other day.
你们可能见过所有那些人，奥普拉（Oprah）、哈里森·福特（Harrison Ford）、王薇薇（Vera Wang）、摩根·弗里曼（Morgan Freeman），他们在40岁时获得了成功。但我只是认为在日常生活中，如果你开始寻找，有太多的故事是关于那些在从未被强调的年龄，或者我们从未预料到成功会降临的年龄找到成功的人。我要给你举个例子。这是一个非常奇怪的例子。但我前几天在阿姆斯特丹。
And I went to this strange museum called the mouse mansion. And whilst we were there, I'm going to be real. It's a children's museum. But my friend Rosie was like, you have to go. It's really endearing. We go. We do a tour. We like paint these little doors for the mice.
我去了一个奇怪的博物馆，叫“老鼠大厦”（Mouse Mansion）。当我们去那里时，说实话，这是一个儿童博物馆。但我的朋友罗西说，你一定要去。它真的很可爱。我们去了。我们参观了一圈。我们给这些小老鼠画了小门。
And this woman, shout out to Eleanor, the host, was telling us the story of, that this museum is like now one of the most famous museums in Amsterdam. And I was like, who made this museum? Like, where did this come from? And she was like, it was this woman in her like, 40s or 50s who had had her kids, had a career, and she just like was having this vision of these mice stories. And she wanted, she wanted to make children's books about mice. And she wanted to make this mice mouse mansion. And she did it. And she found this like level
这位女士，向主持人埃莉诺（Eleanor）致敬，告诉我们这个故事，这个博物馆现在是阿姆斯特丹最著名的博物馆之一。我问，是谁建造了这个博物馆？这是从哪里来的？她说，是一位40多岁或50多岁的女士，她有了孩子，有了事业，她只是有了这些老鼠故事的愿景。她想制作关于老鼠的儿童读物。她想建造这个老鼠大厦。她做到了。她找到了这种水平的
of success and like fame. And she's created all this joy. for other people, like at an age that, like, I don't think society wants you to find particularly extraordinary. Like, finding success in our 40s and 50s like this woman did, like the mouse mansion creator did, is not highlighted as much. But I genuinely think that, like, it is impressive at any age. And it's probably sweeter at that age because you've had all this time for self-exploration. You've had all this time to explore and to make relationships and make memories that maybe you wouldn't have gotten if you were visibly successful. And that all comes back to you in dividends later on. So I think that that's kind of what I want to end to the episode on.
成功和名声。她为其他人创造了所有的快乐，在这样一个年龄，我不认为社会希望你找到特别非凡的东西。像这位女士一样，像老鼠大厦的创造者一样，在40多岁和50多岁时找到成功，并没有被强调得那么多。但我真心认为，在任何年龄这都是令人印象深刻的。而且在那个年龄可能更甜美，因为你有所有这些时间进行自我探索。你有所有这些时间去探索、去建立关系、去创造回忆，如果你在很早的时候就显眼地成功了，你可能就不会得到这些。而这一切以后都会以红利的形式回馈给你。所以我认为这就是我想结束这一集的地方。
The pressure to be extraordinary is immense. All of us have felt in some form or another, whether that is when you were at university, whether you were at high school and it was to perform academically or to find internships, whether it is now to be somebody who is considering viral fame, somebody who posts, somebody who starts a business, somebody who starts an AI tech company, it's like never ending, it's aggressively in our faces, it's not all that it's cracked up to be. The pressure to be extraordinary actually sucks the joy out of life. and I think finding ways to counteract it and to be like, actually, my objective is to have fun, my objective is to have experiences, my objective is to have great relationships is probably going to make you happier
成为非凡的压力是巨大的。我们所有人都以某种形式感受过，无论是在大学时，还是在高中时，是为了学业表现或寻找实习机会，还是现在为了成为一个考虑病毒式传播的名声的人，一个发帖的人，一个创业的人，一个创办人工智能科技公司的人，它似乎永无止境，它咄咄逼人地出现在我们面前，它并不像人们吹嘘的那样好。成为非凡的压力实际上吸干了生活的乐趣。我认为找到抵消它的方法，并说“实际上，我的目标是获得乐趣，我的目标是拥有经历，我的目标是拥有伟大的关系”，可能会让你比我们看到的那些被强调为杰出的人更快乐。
than the people we see highlighted as these exceptional people who, at 40, 50, 60, and now having the realizations of like, who the frick am I that you, were able to have at 20 because you didn't have mega success and you hadn't found yourself before you even knew yourself. So I don't know. That's been what I've been thinking about a lot recently and I think it's a real sign that we need to reinvestigate what is successful and what is extraordinary in our society because I think our current version of it isn't all that it's cracked up to be and doesn't seem to be particularly enjoyable for the people who find it. So that's where I'm going to leave the episode. If you have made it this far and if you are listening
那些人在40、50、60岁时，现在才意识到“我到底是谁”，而你在20岁时就能意识到，因为你没有巨大的成功，而且你在了解自己之前还没有找到自己。所以我不知道。这就是我最近一直在思考的事情，我认为这是一个真正的信号，我们需要重新调查社会中什么是成功的，什么是杰出的，因为我认为我们目前的版本并不像人们吹嘘的那样好，而且对于那些找到它的人来说，似乎并不特别令人愉快。所以这就是我要结束这一集的地方。如果你已经看到了这里，如果你正在收听
on Spotify, what is something in your life right now that you think you should be having more fun doing rather than stressing out as much as you probably are about? Career, hobby, relationship, what is something that you think that you and that you want to focus on enjoying more than you are performing at? Mine is my hobbies. That's an easy one. I feel such a, like, I constantly feel like I need to monetize or make public everything that I do because, like, being in my 20s and living as a 20-something is like my brand. And I'm really trying to be better at just enjoying them for me and seeing where they flow personally. And for me, not where they flow, like, for others and for an audience. So that's my answer. Leave yours below.
在Spotify上，你生活中现在有什么事情是你认为你应该更多地享受乐趣，而不是像你可能正在做的那样感到压力吗？职业、爱好、关系，有什么事情是你认为你想要专注于享受，而不是表现得更好的吗？我的是我的爱好。这是一个简单的例子。我感到一种……我不断地觉得我需要将我所做的一切货币化或公开，因为20多岁并作为20多岁的人生活是我的品牌。我真的在努力做得更好，只是为了我自己享受它们，看看它们在个人层面上如何流动。为了我，而不是为了他人和观众。所以这是我的答案。在下面留下你的。
As always, thank you to our researcher, Lucy Davidson. She helped us out with this episode. She's great. We have full episodes including this one, video episodes on Netflix. That is correct. Probably in your country at this point. Australia, New Zealand, the UK, Canada, the US. I don't know any of the others. I'm Germany. Maybe. I actually don't know. I think it's in Germany. But yeah, go and check it out. If you're in like, if, actually, if you were in Germany, that's your, that is actually your objective. Leave a comment because I don't have German Netflix. so I don't know if it's there, so you can do some research for us. Substack, Instagram, all of those things are also in the episode description,
一如既往，感谢我们的研究员露西·戴维森（Lucy Davidson）。她在这集节目中帮助了我们。她很棒。我们有完整的剧集，包括这一集，Netflix上的视频剧集。这是正确的。此时可能在你的国家。澳大利亚、新西兰、英国、加拿大、美国。我不知道其他的。德国。也许。我其实不知道。我想是在德国。但是的，去看看吧。如果你在德国，那实际上是你的目标。留下评论，因为我没有德国的Netflix，所以我不知道它是否在那里，所以你可以为我们做一些研究。Substack、Instagram，所有这些也在剧集描述中，
as well as some of our favorite resources if you want to do a bit more investigating on the pressure to be extraordinary yourself. But I do just hope you enjoyed this episode. I hope it's made you feel better about your own path. And until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. There was no anything inside the... eyes. They turned black. It scared the hell out of me.
以及一些我们最喜欢的资源，如果你想自己对成为非凡的压力做更多的调查。但我确实希望你喜欢这一集。我希望它让你对自己的道路感觉更好。直到下一次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔。我们很快就会再谈。那些眼睛里没有任何东西。它们变成了黑色。这把我吓坏了。
Evil, wake up. I'm the one that saw the murder take place by Krivac and DePippo. Anthony DePippo showed no signs of remorse, appearing unfazed after being sentenced to the maximum. I said, I'm not guilty. I'll take it to the grief. Listen to the devil's quarry in the Bone Valley Feed on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Joy is essential and it's also elusive, but now there's a new and exciting way to start your journey toward a more joyful existence, Joy 101. It's a new podcast hosted by me, Hoda Kotby.
邪恶，醒醒吧。我是那个看到克里瓦克和德皮波实施谋杀的人。安东尼·德皮波在被判处最高刑罚后，没有表现出任何悔意，显得泰然自若。我说，我没罪。我会带着它进坟墓。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《魔鬼的采石场》。快乐是必不可少的，它也是难以捉摸的，但现在有一种新的、令人兴奋的方式来开始你的旅程，走向更快乐的存在，《Joy 101》。这是一个由我，霍达·科特比主持的新播客。
If you're craving inspiration to maximize your joy, tune into these candid, uplifting, and moving on-air chats. Open your free IHeart Radio app. Search Joy 101 and listen now. Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby is presented by CV. Everyone sees me as a football player, but before anything else, I'm human. Every single day, I'm still learning how to live with problems, mistakes, relationships, emotions, ever since I was born. This isn't a normal podcast.
如果你渴望灵感来最大化你的快乐，请收听这些坦诚、振奋人心和感人的直播聊天。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用程序。搜索《Joy 101》并立即收听。《Joy 101 with Hoda Kotby》由CV呈现。每个人都把我视为一名足球运动员，但在任何事情之前，我首先是一个人。从出生起，我每天都在学习如何处理问题、错误、人际关系和情绪。这不是一个普通的播客。
Everything here is spontaneous, real, and genuine, just honest conversations about what it means to be alive. I'm Javier Tchariot Hernandez and listen to Learning to Be Human on IHard Radio, Apple Podcasts, or whatever you get your podcast. Here's something that should not be as complicated as it is, getting a racist statue removed. And here's something that should be a whole lot easier than it is, getting a new one put up in its place. I'm Akela Hughes, and Rebel Spirit Season 2 is about both of those things. As I was watching these statues come down, I was thinking about what it meant that I grew up in a majority of Black City, in which there were more homages to enslavers than there were to enslave people. Listen to Rebel Spirit Season 2 on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这里的一切都是自发的、真实的、真诚的，只是关于活着意味着什么的诚实对话。我是哈维尔·“小豌豆”·埃尔南德斯，在iHeartRadio、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《学习做人》。这里有一件事不应该像现在这样复杂：移除种族主义雕像。这里有一件事应该比现在容易得多：在原处放置一个新的。我是阿克拉·休斯（Akela Hughes），《Rebel Spirit》第二季就是关于这两件事的。当我看着这些雕像被拆除时，我在想，我在一个黑人占多数的城市长大，那里对奴隶主的致敬比对被奴役者的致敬还要多，这意味着什么。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Rebel Spirit》第二季。
Every family has its secrets. But what happens when you discover that your dad has been living a double life? That is not the look of an innocent man. Is everyone lying to me about who they are? I felt such desperation. I felt it was what I had to do. Listen to Deep Cover the Family Man on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast.
每个家庭都有秘密。但当你发现你的父亲一直过着双重生活时，会发生什么？那不是一个无辜者的样子。每个人都在对我撒谎关于他们是谁吗？我感到如此绝望。我觉得这是我必须做的事情。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或任何你获取播客的地方收听《深度潜伏：顾家男人》。这是一个iHeart播客。
Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
保证是人类。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。